[Musique]
un baiser ça y est tu as ton fric lui
mon matos bah ouais on regarde mes yeux
tu vois tamura regarde moi je te dis tu
vois d'amour
c'est la voiture vous ne raterez jamais
promettre est jamais déçu
je ne puis que vous voyez machine serait
le décide et n'a pas 15 ans julian même
tu peux rien c'est comme ça à la cour
c'est important pour tant que nouveau
public très propre ils heureux disparaît
j'ai un ami de rodolphe qu'est ce que
vous vouliez 30
d'après moi ce que je peux dire que vous
allez pas me faire chanter un tube pas
justement je sais pas toi mais comme
solution pour réparer vos conneries
quand vous avez pu vous mettre dans une
carrière parallèle j'ai vu pour signaler
une disparition
je sais c'est que se passer quelque
chose
je m'appelle m
[Rires]
si j'arrêtais là
tiens toi
c'est quoi ce délire la victoire
quoi que ce soit c'est la bonne décision
survient
enfin je te croyais à présenter là
des mois que nous le rappeler
je la tue mais qu'est ce que tu en
penses
j'ai un sale type tour
l'habitude aurait demandé à personne
aussi justement rien à personne
moi aussi je suis un sale type
[Musique]